welcome to this video part 16 of them
pre World Championship match series be
approaching the match just a couple of
days till the first game and yeah part
16 meet some we're having a counting
game again I've switched colors Carlton
playing black and the game we're looking
at now and this is a bit of a different
game compared to the ones shown before
because it is some plate at the rapids
time control it's a rapid game and also
it was played blind forwarded some both
players played the game without side of
the board which makes them game all the
more interesting so I mean interesting
now and regular chest as interesting as
well but what I'm going to show us some
quite spectacular moves and that these
were plated blindfold blindfold and
rapid tag control so just very nice
played in 2007 there was a world cup in
2007 Rapids blind fold in Bilbao Spain
and yeah let's see what happens kayaking
playing white can scars and so let's see
we have one year for and Carlton going
for the Sicilian which isn't his most
done regularly opening against you for
but he's playing all kinds of lines at
the time he played many times the
special ink off so 96 invites that but
Bishop b5 he played by Aoki nowadays
Bishop b5 is almost the main line
against 96 and some white really has
trouble to show anything in this
rationing cough so more people more and
more switch towards you should be five
yeah I can't special p5 black
mostly two moves on g6 of course
intending to theatre this was my choice
in this position I think almost
exclusively at e6 those are the two main
moves there's also d6 but e6 g6 the main
ideas that he six was played also my
cars the idea is to play Knight g37 to
allow an easy recaptcha on c6 so if
white castles now which is of course a
legitimate line then I g7 is blacks idea
with them this being the point and why
probably won't take him at this is the
general idea get the night to his heaven
right in the game immediately captured
on c6 this is nowadays I think maybe the
most popular move here immediately
making sure that black actually gets
this double pawns and taking the chance
now to inflict this double pole before
ninety seven is played yeah d3 in the
next move and this is interesting why it
is not castling immediately to have more
flexibility in regards to the H porn
yeah th pole yeah the ideas black now
plays 97 and quite often the night goes
to g6 which is a pretty decent square
for the night supporting e65 and
controlling y to the dark squares the
night on g6 ever is also subjected to an
attack by h4 h5 and this is why white
has not cashed out yet he wants to be
flexible in regards to the smooth
Queenie to the same policy not castling
and towns near place Quincy 7 the main
move here is in fact 96 which is usually
answered by age from intending furthered
once so black probably needs to play h5
and then after five we have a very
interesting complex position with the
chances for both sides and white has a
pretty decent score in this line but
it's still very complicated and um yeah
some sort of uneven position where both
sides have their strengths and the
weaknesses another place Quincy seven
which has some a bit of a decent waiting
it doesn't want to put the night there
early and asks right okay what are you
going to play now if you castle for
instance then there's 96 gains in
strength so something like that
certainly is better than in this version
h4 as possible p h4 doesn't really make
any sense without the book on h1 so
castles is not really am doing much
kayaking plays very aggressive move
replace night g5 yes I know he moves the
same piece twice and one possible idea
is this very crude attack with the Queen
but also using the F porn f four
possibly even f5 if mine is cancelled so
when an aggressive and also a good move
this is some an interesting way to
proceed very directly yeah a form as
mentioned as one idea Carlson now in
place b5 now directly working against a
form but it damn it cannot really am
be prevented white plays f4 anyway I was
just thinking um what is blacks reply to
to this move you can just play f6 no
trouble on f7 yeah a force plate and
again the most aggressive move your
black doesn't really have any choice you
you need to grab this pawn if you play
yeah slow move it's not even easy to
find one as why it is really threatening
to take on e5 yeah really need to
capture there's not much else now
castles with the idea to play Bishop f5
and black is pretty much wiped out
directly so 96 all forced white place
Queen h5 so black is unlearn an early
pressure this is a very aggressive
attacking duel and it's not so clear how
black cow should untangle him especially
if you consider the direct threats
they're down that I in the position um
let's for example consider Bishop e7
trying to prepare castle at some point
this is answered by Bishop f4 and this
is one idea of course of Queen age 5
this pressure on f7 if black now take
here check the simple capture would
would basically win the game that's
night f7 and there is various problems I
mean that f7 can you check may even be a
direct mate but after this what is this
additional idea and where's this night
going to go it's a it's just a very very
strong attack that black will not be
able to repel
so this is a really a direct threat
black needs to to be aware of that and
react accordingly they are various
interesting with some for example even
Queenie five which looks at saying at
first as fit as a playable move not the
move cards played but still something
you could could consider Bishop takes
Queen takes and 92 and white is got
various attacking ideas um however this
kind of or the style of play grabbing
pawns moving your queen multiple times
um yeah it's questionable on a via
general it is quite questionable but
consider this is a blind light forward
rapid game so you really should try to
like wrap the initiative and get a
position that you have some easy moves
to play and then you don't really want
to give her the opponent this big big
attack some should look for alternative
ways to play I will calculate them
strongly played d6 this is covering this
vital square sideways and of course also
initiates a forcing sequence now why
takes on f4 this was to be expected he
needs to get something on the FR so this
was was clear and what should like do
now one interesting point is that the
move h6 it's not really good because why
it can take on f7 yeah this is very game
winning the Queen and this is not not
that easy but still a very good position
white if you look at at this for example
and Whitehead is an excellent game he
will get this third porn and we'll have
night see for coming up with an
excellent attack and you don't even know
I don't have any material sacrificed so
an excellent position for white which
means that age 6 this move is not
playable you need to do something else
I'm thousand finds another solution he
takes on air for rook takes and now it
it really looks very dangerous black
only has the Queen moved and it's
defending f7 but it's not really a yeah
it's not really enough to defend their 7
ball so what should black play in heck
there's only one way to proceed now play
g6 easy moose and Queen back now there's
maximum pressure on f7 so what look like
play now and his plane very very strong
sequences moves now always remember
rapid light fold um yeah the first move
you're probably going to consider here
is Bishop age six at least this is a
move that that I would probably consider
first it puts up this pin and in general
how are you going to defend this anyway
you need to to do some or to find some
security technical solution here so must
be something like visual page six okay
let's check oops not that one you page
six rook takes and queen a5 this is the
line that can be examined now the 90s
hang and
as Queen you one as an additional threat
but the problem is that in this position
right can simply develop 93 Bishop takes
Andrew gave on that white is a piece
down but just position is so strong it's
an absolutely indefensible attack for
example if black plays Bush will be six
there's 'if I've coming and black has no
defense IAM let's say d hive for example
there's the very strong move rook f6 and
and white is in fact even winning a
problem is some yeah no don't move here
if takes Queen takes the rook is hanging
like cannot castle and Jesus is also not
helping so on you don't really have a
move this is of course an additional
problem so um oops this was too much
just wanted to quickly go back to this
here there really no moves but should
like do if you play something like that
the same key seven check yeah many
attacking waste bishop h6 for exactly
that reason is failing so on what is
this there you can consider Bishop to e6
just just covering but look at this
position just briefly it looks really
ugly white is coming here with rook
everyone it has this very strong fr it's
not really attractive and in addition
you you
need to take here immediately white can
also first develop 92 or 93 it's not an
attractive option council played the
strongest move Bishop to d7 at first you
think white Mason this isn't this big
problem look f7 yeah we have seven is
indeed one was played we briefly should
check in night f7 native 7s answered by
castles simple and strong now this night
is hanging and you don't really have a
square to go to do to g5 but simply this
is going to win the rook so Brooke f7
this is the way to go and that it looks
terrible at first the rookies just
attacking two pieces gang hat Carlson
has a very nice resource he plates check
out this check King to h1 yeah white
also could consider looking to everyone
but it's a very unnatural move to blame
the answers just like in the game Queen
to d8 we can look at the game and you
can maybe keep King everyone in mind
King edge one is the toughest yeah as
mentioned Queen d8 is the one that was
played and this is really really
difficult to calculate beforehand
consider its blindfold chess even yeah
those kind of backward moves that attack
on g5 and why this is really mean he's
attacking oops this wasn't planned he's
attacking with Queen look at night and
it looks like somehow there's just like
one check and it's check media but there
is no no yeah there is no little
combination that delivers the made
something like this yeah
nice meshak nake but of course the Queen
can take and you just blundered the rook
you don't have any of those little
deadly combinations that that net you
the point am simply simply not there but
White has many a possible options and
one idea for example is to take on h7
like this but of course I can take on b2
and now the problem is if white plays
'if I've attacking on c6 and introducing
this idea and this idea quite a lot and
this black can simply answer with
Queenie seven funny enough because
squeegee Essex check King me eight Queen
88 and now queen age 7 has quite a
simple wind for black hole will pick up
the rukon on a one so taking my age
seven this is not really great white can
also try i takes age 71 idea of the
night captures that Bishop takes be too
can be answered by them the strong move
Knight c3 looks a bit strange but it's
in fact very strong if the group the
bishop would take on a one does Rita
hate coming check check
channel this one check check check yeah
very long sequence but it's all forced
all checks and black needs to give up
the Queen which will probably win for
white ok blacks got two bishops and the
rook but dad just too many points plus
this rather became king let's let's take
this back this is very long this line
but still it's it's relevant let's check
again night h7 takes and 93 but ok black
does not need to take here you can also
consider to take on on oops take care of
course sorry look everyone then is the
idea of course getting everything on the
F file and here this is the move you you
need to check but it also does not
really help why it can can take here and
take on g6 check and this attack will be
decisive so let's check again night h7
so is this some the best move maybe it
is but black shouldn't take on be to
this is too risky I can take Bishop f5
ok play at Bishop f5 and this is
probably ok for him as now the look is
detect it doesn't really have a good
square so Brooke takes and five is the
best answer g takes and object green h5
check king d7 Queen f5 and King back it
probably should end in a draw this is a
check actual check and this is probably
the logical outcome of the game but this
didn't happen
kayaking played another move not a bad
move played c3 attacking the bishop and
here in fact cards had a good
alternative maybe even a better
alternative to what he played he played
the Bishop to b5 they could have taken
on g4 if this was an interesting way to
go after takes on d4 Quincy one check
check it's a big point quit f1 and take
back this position is probably about
equal black can try with Bishop a6 to
put some pressure on d3 but why should
be able to defend this um this is
probably a good alternative for black
but he didn't do that he played Bishop
to g5 and exactly here in this position
kayaking commits the decisive mistake
but it's very very tricky obviously this
position what should why do the best
move it seems here is the with age form
and we will see why this is the best
move basically yeah by studying the game
age six let's let me show you the game
and then I'll show why h4 was better he
played Ruby 7 which looks very strong at
first because we have seven mate not not
bad at all at first you think wait this
is nonsense I can just play rook evade
the druggie of eight is met by a strong
answer look to g8 it's quite nice
threatening made this one and if black
takes here checkmate also made so this
needs to be played and here check check
check yeah this is one possibility but
this is even stronger intending the
quicker look at one why does just
winning a pony in the long run there's
also night see form with a good a good
attack against the six white is already
upon up anyway so very good for white so
what is the problem with ruka g7 yeah
the problem is what what cards are
played you played a queen to f6 this is
very strong the difference by the way if
white would have played h4 here the
difference is if low age six and rook g7
quite similar then Queen f6 it's no
problem at all because there's this line
or alternatively after look at eight
white can play just rookie have seven
back and after you catch a droop t7 we
again have a perpetual or repetition of
moves with a draw each form was better
but loud let's check wine group g7 as
mentioned was played and now Queen f6
white this move so strong yeah the
problem is if if you look at this now
the rook is threatened and yet white can
try to take h7 but after after this
there's simply Queenie seven and no way
to to keep this night it's just wrapped
so rook takes h7 is not playable so
where should it go through c7 you can
just take check this is just one check
and no attack whatsoever so what should
why do yeah the only move basically is
to exchange I have six this is what you
did Bishop takes and now I'm the funny
point that really needed to be
calculated much much earlier rook takes
age 7 and at first you think wait hmm I
probably have to have to take now and
after that it's not clear if black is
going to capture this night it's almost
wrapped but it's not so clear cut so
yeah but what else yeah in fact black
has a very strong move in cards and
played the move just castles you can
sometimes forget about those kind of
moves if you ND ç kind of extreme
situations where this rook is attacked
and the ol king position is wide open
you sometimes forget that you can castle
and black cat castle here and it's a
very strong move it's almost double
attack the king is attacking the rook
and the bishop is attacking the knight
and it's very difficult to cover both in
fact it's not only difficult it's
impossible at first maybe you think you
can give this trigger drive like that
jack but take note that checkmate that
you made it here Luke age six is not
working as well so on at the end it all
comes to a set truth or white the piece
is lost yeah quite funny the son
this sequence after Luke g7 is just
great we have six you need to trade
takes and then castles is the winning
move with a double attack so castle in
with a double attack you don't see that
too often and it's um it's a blindfold
game they didn't see the board so a
great effort to to enter this position
with the look on f7 which looks very
threatening and then find those
defensive resources to resources not not
only to ya to not get meet it or keep
the position imbalance but but to win a
piece yeah kayaking and continued the
game simply because of time control and
bleep it being a blind for game you
played 93 and of course just take the
piece look see 780 okay Black has more
than one good move you played rook f7
getting getting to this this sequence
and this is a strong move again like
tries to get the bishop to e5 and covers
this sensitive porn 94 and Bishop d7
this is not too difficult but let's
let's show it anyway because it's still
instructive especially this this double
attack and the capture leads to a
position where black has an excellent
piece on e5 which is not yeah not
endangered by any pawn or any attack
it's just an eternal great bishop only 5
and black now easily can improve this
piece position is looks especially of
course to attack the weak white pawns
and quite quickly we see that it's very
difficult for why to avoid an immediate
loss and in fact he only has swiped
a couple of extra moves before I try it
but Carson just grabbed the spa and
centralizes the bishop and now the
second rank is so decisive rook a 2
takes a Droog f2 yeah of course white
cannot take it because of Jack yeah okay
this is this is more precisely the
immediate mate cannot take in chan this
of course threatens rapage to mate so
then cap just kind of revenge checks and
now ki can reside in view of the coming
mate which cannot really be prevented so
keep in mind a rapid blindfold game and
I really liked the the coda fancier to
allow whites to take on f7 and that
calculated precisely that this check and
queen d 8 despite looking really strange
because the soul of a yeah developing
the Queen back to back to the two da to
its initial square to to see that this
is in fact okay for black is really
great considering that it was played
with outside of the board white could
have gotten an equal or unclear position
out of this but he didn't manage and
played this mistake a move but it's it's
very easy to overlook this this type of
move short castles which is really the
star move of the game also um take note
that this is this meeting idea of nf1
this is really an additional problem
alright i hope you liked this game a bit
of a different different game from the
classical time control games but i
thought it was very interesting
defensive effort that very nicely showed
the resources you sometimes have like
short castles here that you can easily
overlook alright thanks for watching
I'll be back tomorrow with the part 17